veamos aquí dice una de las temperaturas
más frías fue registrada en antártica de
menos 128 grados fahrenheit y una de las
temperaturas más cálidas fue de 134
grados fahrenheit esto fue en el valle
de la muerte california entonces la
pregunta es cuántos grados de diferencia
hay entre la temperatura más fría y la
más caliente pensando en esto un poco lo
que haré es colocar una recta numérica
vertical para que parezca un termómetro
y aquí vamos a porque estamos hablando
de temperatura entonces aquí voy a poner
la recta numérica vertical y más o menos
por aquí estará el 0 0 grados fahrenheit
lo cual no es muy relevante porque si
fueran grados celsius nos estaríamos
congelando pero en este caso en
fahrenheit
el congelamiento sucede hasta los 32
grados entonces digamos que ahí está 0
grados fahrenheit y lo que voy a hacer
es colocar
en estos puntos en la recta numérica
vertical ahora aquí dice que la
temperatura más fría fue de menos 128
grados fahrenheit que sería más o menos
por aquí y digamos que una de las
temperaturas más cálidas fue de 134
grados que está más o menos por acá es
un número positivo y ahora bien cuando
nos piden la diferencia que hay entre la
temperatura más fría y la más caliente
lo que esencialmente nos están pidiendo
es cual cual es la distancia que hay
aquí cuánto mide esta distancia entre la
temperatura más fría y la más caliente
hay varias maneras de pensar en esto una
de ellas es iniciar en la más fría y
subes hasta la más caliente entonces
piensas cuánto debo sumar o puedes
pensar en la diferencia que hay entre la
más fría y la más caliente así que
puedes tomar el número mayor que en este
caso es 134 ya esto le resta es el
número menor entonces le vamos a restar
128 negativos
menos 128 y con esto sabremos cuál es la
diferencia que hay entre estos dos
números ajam y será un número positivo
porque estamos restando le al número
mayor el número menor y esto te dará
exactamente esta distancia ahora hay
maneras diferentes de hacer esto la
primera sería sabemos que si restamos un
número negativo esto es lo mismo que
sumar el positivo entonces lo que quiero
decir con esto es que esto de aquí es
exactamente lo mismo que 134 más 128
y por qué sucede esto observa que si
queremos queremos conocer esta distancia
cierto entonces a esta distancia es lo
mismo que 134 esta distancia
esto que estoy marcando aquí
134 más esta otra distancia del 0 al 128
y sumando estas dos distancias la rosa y
la verde tenemos la distancia total la
cuales es la que nos están pidiendo así
que simplemente sumamos esas dos
distancias y tenemos la respuesta
y ahora viene 134 menos menos 128 es
igual a 134 más 128 lo cual es igual
esto de aquí es igual voy a poner aquí
esto es igual de hecho lo voy a hacer a
cada parte
y pongo aquí 134 128 más 128 esto es 84
es igual a 12 uno más tres más dos es
igual a seis y dos más dos es igual a
dos
la respuesta es 262 grados fahrenheit
así que cuántos grados de diferencia hay
entre la temperatura más fría y la más
cálida son 262 grados fahrenheit